there's an aspect of Islam
>> that is
like like the the the scripture you just
cited that is uh I guess violent um and
um and there's a contention there that
this idea of peaceful Muslims, moderate
Muslims
>> and
I guess yeah I I I I'm not sure exactly
what my question here is but I
>> the origins of all this how it all
>> Yeah. Yeah. like how much is this from
the Quran? How much is this from
Muhammad? What's your perspective on
that?
>> Yeah. Okay. It's all you have to
understand how Islamic law works. Okay.
So according to Islamic teaching amongst
Sunnis who are 90% of the Muslim world
um you know the twin the twin sources of
authority are the Quran which is
understood to be the literal words of
Allah and then what's called the hadith.
Okay plural it's a hadith but I'm going
to say hadiths to anglicize it. And um
all they are are vast va volumes and
volumes and volumes of what Muhammad
supposedly said and did. Okay. And
according to the Muslim, you know,
scientists as they call themselves, you
know, they rank them. There's what's
called sah, meaning it's correct. It's
authentic. He did say this. And that
takes on almost the same value as a
Quran. Okay?
>> And there's a lot of that. Now based on
those two things,
hatred for the non-Muslim is unequivocal
and continuously documented. War on them
as jihad, continuously documented. Uh
treating, you know, the non-Muslim who
gets conquered as a vimi, which means
they have to live as a secondass citizen
and pay tribute, unequivocally
documented. These are totally enshrined
based on the Quran and the words of
Muhammad. Okay, his example. And
Muslims, the word Sunni, I mentioned
them. it uh the Sunni means like the
example. So there a Sunni is trying to
follow the example of Muhammad. So
Muhammad wage war and infidels that's
what we have to do as well. So it's
unequivocally clear you know anyone a
person will tell you that no Islam
doesn't teach violence etc. He's either
really really ignorant or being very
very deceptive and it could be one or
the other. Um but if you've taken the
time to study them as I have in their
original languages and that's another
problem. If you look at the Quran today,
it's it they're mistransating it
intentionally. They add words that don't
exist, you know. So, for example, Quran
9:29 will say which literally says fight
the people of the book, which means Jews
and Christians until they pay tribute
and feel themselves subdued. Okay? And
that's that's the teaching that come
that's what justifies Jiza. It uses the
word Jiza. Um, a lot of English now
Quran translations say fight the people
of the book if they fight you first.
Okay. And okay, so now it doesn't look
so bad. This is again defensive war.
This is just war. The original doesn't
say they fight you first. Says you
attack them. So there's unfortunately a
lot of playing around with Islamic
scriptures intent in intended to deceive
infidels. Um but yeah, that it's it's
just it's that simple. That's what the
two twin pillars of Islamic the the
Islam Islam's authority, the Quran
hadith say.
>> And the Quran is the word of God.
I read the Quran a few years ago and it
what the difficult thing for me apart
from certain of some certain of the
scriptures like the ones mentioned
already is that it says throughout it
you must take this literally and you
can't swear.
So the idea of a sort of Islamic
reformation against this is seems to be
tricky. Having said that and I'll come
back to Europe, but I look around the
world now where I have hope with
relations between the western world and
the Islamic world is the leaders of
let's say the Emirati leaders uh where
where the the the signatories of the
Abraham Accords and I see oh actually
these are people who are taking Islamism
seriously. They recognize the problem.
They're even calling the westerners out
for not taking it serious enough. Um the
Emiratis have been fantastic on this,
particularly Muhammad bin Zed.
>> Um for me, the hope is that these people
are interpreting the the scripture in a
certain way that means that there will
be
>> uh relations much improved from
everything you've described in history.
Do you think I'm I'm right to feel this
way?
>> No, I I think there's room for optimism
for for a number of reasons. you know,
the the the the hur the insurmountable
hurdle is what I just described. Okay,
the texts are so black and white. You
know, it literally says in the Quran
that if you're a Muslim, you have to
hate non-Muslims. And I've watched
cleric after cleric say things like,
"Yeah, even if you're married, because
Islam allows Muslim men to marry
Christian women or Jews." And he'll say,
"Yeah, you can marry them and have fun
with them sexually, but you have to hate
them and you have to let them know you
hate them." Okay, that's that's how much
it's so ironclad. Now, you know, and
this is the whole question about what's
a moderate Muslim. Okay. So, yeah, I
don't believe in a moderate Islam
because it's just not there. It's black
and white. But I do believe in moderate
Muslims because humans are subjective
and they can do whatever they want,
right? They can believe they can just
reinterpret it their own way. They can
ignore it. I mean, so I believe you have
that. It exists. It's just it's very
hard to doctrinally justify it, okay,
against the hardliners. That's why they
always end up winning the arguments
because it goes back to what the Quran
says and what the hadith says. Okay. But
there's all kinds of leeway and and you
know ways to get around this I suppose.
>> Um
>> but you're right a lot of people what
they don't they say we want a pro they
say we want a reformation of Islam and
what they don't get is actually
something very akin to the Protestant
Reformation has been happening and it's
what led to radicalism. Okay, not
because Protestantism is radical, but
the same methodology and I'll explain
what I'm saying. Protestantism
essentially uh was, you know, solo
scriptura. We don't we're done with
clergies and whatever. We just want the
Bible. Okay. And um Islam before for a
while has always been yeah the Quran and
the Sunnah, but most people were
illiterate Muslims and you had to rely
on the and the scholars and the shakes
etc. And there were schools of law and
there still are which could you know
modify teachings certain ways or not.
Well, like the Protestant Reformation,
you know, since modern times, now the
Quran is available on the internet,
okay? And people, Muslims are literate
and they can read Arabic. And what's
happening is they're becoming more and
more going back to the scriptures and
not caring so much about what the
schools of law they're called say. So,
it's a it's almost like a solos scriptor
mentality. But the but the result is the
exact opposite. Because if you're a
Christian who just goes by the Bible,
well, you're going to turn the other
cheek and you're going to love your
neighbor and you're going to believe in
monogamy, etc., etc. If you go strictly
with what I'm talking about, the Quran
and the Hadith, well, that's where all
the hatred comes and the violence and
basically a 7th century Bedawin
mentality. I mean, that's that's what's
captured there.
>> So, what people really want is not um a
pro not a reformation of Islam, which I
don't think is possible. They wanted an
enlightenment which was basically you
know not even caring what the scriptures
say and just rising above it and uh you
know how you rationalize that people can
do whatever they want. I mean and look
amongst Christians you have all kinds of
different beliefs and teachings even
though one Christian will say no the
Bible says this and so of course it can
be done um but you're going to need and
the leaders you have to remember they
can do what they can do but a lot of the
you know the people are you know Saudi
Arabia is our good friend and ally and I
know they're also sometimes part of
these accords etc but they're also the
chief disseminators of radical Islam
okay they're the ones who fund this you
know if you go to a mosque in in England
And you find it has radical hateful
books. It's coming from Saudi Arabia,
>> you know. So it's and again we have to
contend with this idea of ta Islam
allowing deception of the infidel as
needed. Okay. So we're in a weak phase
then we have to you know be
accommodating to them and not hate them
openly. So all that needs to be taken
into consideration. But having said
that, I think if Western powers or the
non-Muslim world just dropped the act
and said, "Look, we understand your
religion. We understand it has violence
and we understand this, but we're not
going to tolerate it." And you know, in
other words, call them out and stop
playing this game as if no, no, it's not
there. It is there. Let's confront it
and let's work around it.
>> I suspect if you were to do that, then
you a lot of the problems might go away.
Yeah.
>> Because if you just you call it out and
everyone's like, "Actually, we better
behave."
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> but if you keep acting, no, no, your
religion means peace. There's nothing
wrong with your religion. Okay, so it's
you're not addressing the problem.
>> Well, this brings me to what's going big
scandal in my country, the grooming gang
scandal where tens of thousands of young
>> Rotherham
>> Rother. Exactly. Uh young white
underclass girls predominantly white. Um
there's some other Hindu girls and and
different groups but mainly white have
been targeted because they are quote
>> kafir
>> and uh kafir or kafar is
>> kafir is singular kafar is plural
>> kufur and it it's still now contentious
you can't call it what it is because the
perpetrators are predominantly Pakistani
heritage
>> uh grooming gangs um even calling them a
grooming gang isn't quite it's the rape
gang rape gangs is is what they really
are um and um
we're just sort of unable to uh call out
that that kind of stuff. We also have
we've Islamist attack after Islamist
attack. This is kind of across Europe.
It's a it's a problem and and this is
this is what I I kind of want to your
whole history. I wonder how we can uh
make it relevant to what's going on now
because you sort of given a historical
context and
Muslims are moving to Europe on mass in
in in hugely growing Muslim populations
particularly in contrast with a
declining let's say quotequote
indigenous population uh Christian
population and Christianity is also on
the decline anyway amongst those. Um, so
I I I wanted your perspective on on how
we might find social cohesion
today in Europe.
>> Sure. Um, so let me give you some more
context because you're right, you know,
the history I I told you and there's
still elements of it that we need to
talk about to make sense of what you're
discussing. Um so one of the you know
one of the earliest motifs amongst
Islamic scholars and this goes back to
about the 8th 9th centuries was that um
you know and I hate to put it this way
but that's how they put it like white
women want it okay and white women are
desirable and they're the and I was
telling you about the Vikings bringing
slaves they wanted fair slaves this is a
well doumented thing that goes back to
Muhammad you know for during one
campaign the the campaign against it's
called Tabuk where he was supposed to
fight the Eastern Roman empires which
would be Greeks he actually tried tried
to cajul men to join him by saying don't
you want the people of yellow and and
and then he talks about the women how
beautiful they are but yellow I assume
means hair a lot of people try to
understand what that means does it mean
hair fair skin whatever um so there's a
long kind of like this almost like say m
masochistic thing of presenting white
women as wanting it and just like okay
so now fast forward and what you're
talking about believe it or not because
I've looked into it very closely and the
Muslims the Pakistanis and whatnot they
use the same exact logic and they quote
that and they say, "Yeah, Islam already
told us these people want it and that's
what they're for and they like it, etc.,
etc." So, just, you know, something to
keep in back.
>> Actual quote from Muhammad.
>> Yeah.
>> In a hadith.
>> Yeah. The the quote is that he basically
said, um, you know, uh, don't you want
the the people of yellow, you know, like
come join me on this raid so we can get
pretty blonde women, basically.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. And um but even I you know I'm
saying it starts with N but you find
iterations of this all throughout. Okay
you know most khifs people don't know
this but uh you know even amongst the
Ottomans but especially in Spain you
know their last khif was something like
99% white. Why? Because every sultan
would mate with white women you know and
he would you know be half diluted.
>> So at the very end a lot of these
sultans were essentially blonde hair and
blueeyed but they're Muslim sultans
right? Uh so this is so anyway my point
is this group so you bring a Muslim
population that thinks this way and you
put them in England what do you think is
going to happen and you teach women to
be promiscuous or whatever you know free
love etc what's going to happen this is
going to happen obviously